thomas bonjour la russie s'est réveillé
ce matin avec un nouveau premier
ministre
quelles sont les dernières informations
dont vous disposez eh bien on a appris
dans le courant de la matinée que le
choix de ce nouveau premier ministre
avait été approuvée par le parti
majoritaire à la douma d'état
le groupe russie unie a appuyé à
l'unanimité le choix du nouveau premier
ministre monsieur michu steen qui a
déclaré que sa priorité sera l'exécution
du message du président reste maintenant
pour les prochaines étapes à former un
gouvernement il pourrait y avoir des
changements selon les premières
informations qui circulent ici à moscou
une nomination donc d'un nouveau premier
ministre suite à l'annoncé surprise hier
de la démission de dimitri medvedev et
de son gouvernement
une démission qui fait suite elle au
discours annuel de vladimir poutine
il a exprimé hier sa volonté de
soumettre à un vote populaire des
réformes constitutionnelles ce qui a
donc entraîné la démission surprise de
dimitri medvedev vous propose d'écouter
la réaction de ses habitants de moscou
oui j'ai entendu dire que le
gouvernement avait démissionné
était ce quelque chose de prévisible
selon vous non je ne m'y attendais pas
mais je suis pas beaucoup la situation
politique dans le pays à vrai dire je
l'assumé pas trop ce qu'est john wayne
et son groupe à quoi pensez-vous que
quelque chose va changer avec le nouveau
gouvernement va-t-il influencer la vie
des russes je crains que ce soit encore
pire
la confiance dans le président tombe de
plus en plus ce que montrent les indices
et ça fait peur c'est vrai que ça fait
peur en général compte tenu des
événements récents il y a eu des
suppositions sur internet
[Musique]
une vidéo a été mise en ligne où les
gens répondait à des questions il disait
qu'il s'attendait à la démission du
gouvernement
suite au discours devant l'assemblée
fédérale vladimir poutine qui a appelé
les membres du gouvernement actuel à
poursuivre leur travail et leurs devoirs
jusqu'à la nomination de leurs
successeurs des nominations dont qui
pourrait intervenir très prochainement
merci thomas bonnet pour toutes ces
précisions
en direct de moscou